back when Tara Reid made these
allegations against Joe Biden some on
the right called the left out as
Hypocrites and what those on the right
said to those on the left was listen on
the one hand you leftists say we should
believe all women and then Tara Reid
comes forward forward and says Biden
assaulted me and you don't believe Tara
Reid and so it's important to understand
that believe all women in principle
doesn't mean
you blindly indefinitely believe every
single allegation and this has always
been the case this was what I said when
Justice Kavanaugh was accused this was
what I've always said the right wing
wants to use Tara Reid's allegations to
say that Democrats and leftists actually
have a double standard on me too